اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
بانوراما في عناوين ملفات هذا المساء
نتنياهو في مواجهه الشارع وقواته تستخدم
القنابل والضربه والاعتقالات للسيطره على
الوضع فهل ينجح رئيس الحكومه بمصالحه
المتظاهرين ام ان المواجهات في طريقها
للانفجار
في الملف الثاني اسلحه امريكيه جديده الى
تايوان وواشنطن تهدد بكين بالعقوبات ان
زودت روسيا بالسلاح هل تزيد الصفقه التوتر
مع الصين وكيف سترد بكين على معايير
واشنطن المزدوجه
وفي الملف الثالث روبوت شارجي بي تي يثير
الجدل والمخاوف هل سيحرم ذكاء الاصطناعي
مباشره من وظائفهم وكيف يمكن السيطره على
سيل المعلومات المزيفه التي يوفرها روبوت
تشيلسي بيتي
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل توتر وفوضى وغضب
شعبي هذا هو الحال في اسرائيل حيل خطط
الحكومه لتغيير النظام القضائي حيث يستمر
المتظاهرون بالاحتجاج ما ادى الى استخدام
الشرطه الجزائريه لقنابل الصوت لتفريقهم
بعد اغلاقهم شوارع رئيس في تل ابيب
بالاضافه الى اعتقالات واعتداءات طالت
المتظاهرين الغضب وصل الى منزل نتنياهو
حيث حاصره اسرائيليون غاضبون احتجاجا على
التعديلات في النظام القضائي كما اشتبك
المئات من المتظاهرين مع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه امام صالون لتصفيف الشعر
وسطات تل ابيب قيل ان زوجه رئيس الوزراء
ساره نتنياهو كانت بداخلك رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو علق على هذه الاحداث
وقال انه لن يقبل بالعنف حواره او في تل
ابيب مؤكدا انها تعد خطوطا حمراء لن يتم
التسامح معها كما معارضه الاسرائيليه بعدم
المسؤوليه والتحريض على تظاهرات داعيا الى
التهدئه ووقف العنف وايجاد سبيل للحوار من
جانب اخر رفض المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه رفض تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي اسمه
قريه حوار الفلسطينيه واصفا هذه التصريحات
بغير المسؤوله والمثيره للاشمئزاز هذا
التطور يتزمن مع زياره متوقعه لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي الى اسرائيل نهايه
الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن ان نقبل العنف وضربه ضباط الشرطه
لا يمكن ان نقبل اغلاق الطرق وتهديد
الشخصيه العامه وعائلاتهم وهو امر يحدث في
هذه اللحظه بالضبط في قلب تل ابيب لن نقبل
خلق القواعد والعنف في حواره وفي تل ابيب
وفي اي مكان
ناقش هذه التطورات مع ضيوفنا منزل ابيب
راو فين باركو امني سابق ومحاضر ومن تل
ابيب كذلك الدكتور يحنن سوريف كبير
الباحثين في معهد الامن القومي اهلا بكم
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع سيد باركو سيد باركو
هذه الاحتجاجات هل يمكن لنتنياهو ان
يضبطها ام ان الامور قد فلتت
مساء الخير لك ولا المشاهدين
سفير
بخصوص ما يدور الان في شوارع اسرائيل هو
احتجاج شرعي وهو من ضمن
النظام الديمقراطي الاسرائيلي امر شرقي
ومقبول هناك بعض
مظاهر
الاستثنائيه اسميها حيث ان بعض المتظاهرين
يعملون يعني يسد الطرق ضد القانون
الاسرائيلي وهم يعلمون ذلك وهم مدفوعين من
قبل بعض
الشخصيات والزعماء الذين لا يشقى يستهدفون
الى اي تسويه مستقبليه ولكن الاغلبيه
الساحقه من المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي يشارك
التظاهرات هذا امر شرعي عندما
رجالات الشرطه لتدخل لمنع اللي خالف
القانون لمن تشكير الطرق هذا يعني مسرحيه
اخرى
ويعني الامر لا يهدد السلام في الحكومه او
فلتان كما سميته هذا الامر تعودنا منذ
سنين في مناسبات اخرى في الاخلاق
المواطنين من متعه غزه في بعض المناسبات
السياسيه الغير مقبوله من قبل اطارات
معينه من الشعب وقبولها من فترات اخرى في
شعب هذا هو المظهر ديمقراطي صحيح وعلى
القول ان يحترمه شيئا لا يشاء تعتبره
حضرتك مظهر ديمقراطي رغم ان الشعارات
المرفوعات تنادي بالحريه بالديمقراطيه
بالحقوق بالمساواه يعني البعض يطرح كذلك
هكذا سؤال كانت اسرائيل حقيقيه كما تدعي
ولكن
هل ترك ضيفي بان هذه المظاهرات التي تخطت
مئات الملايين يعني في تل ابيب نتحدث عن
300 الالف 3000
مش باص ثلاث مئه الف يعني عدد كبير مش
ملايين من بعد استرجعت وصححه وصححت صحيح
ولكن سيد صريف هل تعتقد بان هذه المظاهرات
لن تمس من وحده الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا الكلام يعني هو السابق لاوانه يعني
صعب نحكم الان لوين سنصل بعد كل هذه
المظاهرات اولا مساء الخير لكم وكمان الى
اللقاء معكم هناك
شوفي الامور موجوده في حاله صراع الشعب
الاسرائيلي موجود في حاله صراع الداخلي
محاولات الحكومه الحاليه لتغيير
النوعيه النظام الاسرائيلي هي الذي تدفع
المظاهرين الى خروج الى الشوارع
وهذا بحد ذاته يعني اذا لا يحصل تغيير في
هذه المواقف او في هذا الاتجاه الحكومي في
النهايه ستكون
المظاهرات اكثر عنيفه واكثر
تزداد تزداد
حضورها هناك انا باعتقادي من تجربتنا
الطويله الامد ومن
التجريبات الماضي انا اعتقد اكثر امكانيه
الوصول الاحتمال الوصول لحل وسطه اكثر من
الانزلاق الى الى
تعزيز التوتر في هذه في الشوارع لان الكل
يفهم ما هي ما قد تكون هذه نتيجه هذه
المظاهرات وهذا الصراع الذي موجود احنا
سمعنا من اليوم انه في هناك محاولات من
داخل
احزاب الحكوميه وغير حكوميه
من نوع من حل الوسط وعلينا ان نامل او
ننتظر لهذه
النقاش لوين يوصلنا في نهايه صحيح ونحن
سنتابع ذلك ولكن سيدرا فين هل هذه
المظاهرات هي مظاهرات خرجت للتنديد بمشروع
القرار القضائي او مشروع التعديل قضاء
الاخير ام ان هذه المظاهرات اخذت شكل اخر
لان الشعارات المرفوعه اليوم نفهم منها
بانه هناك
تنديد بهذه الحكومه بعملها بتصريحاتها
بافعالها بطريقه تعاملها مع داخل
الاسرائيلي
سؤالك سيدتي الكريمه سؤال جيد جدا وصحيح
لانه من يتعامل مع الجماهير الاسرائيليه
وكانها كيان موحد ذو صبغه واحده فهو غلطان
هناك بعض الاطارات التي تقوم بالاحتجاجات
ولكن
زي ما يعني ممكن بشكل استثنائي
اقسمها لقسمين بعض القادات الذين يحددون
المصطلحات حتى عسكريه انقلابيه
بالانجليزي يعني يستعملون مصطلحات زي تدخل
عسكري واستعمال سلاحه ولا قله قليله من
الذين يشاركون ويحركون ولكن الاغلبيه
الساحقه فعلا قلقانين
يعني من
الخطوات القادمه بما يسمى
بماء يسمى
تغيير في
في تغيير
طبيعه الحكومه
الاسراءات القضائيه
الفرقه الاولى والمجموع الاولى تريد ازاله
نتنياهو حيث انهم فشلوا في الانتخابات
ويحاولون يائسين
يسقطوا الحكومه بطريق غير الديمقراطيه
ولكن هذه المجموعه هامشيه اذا اردت اصمم
هذه الاسماء
ولكن قبل ان تسمي بعض الاسماء سيده صحيح
ولكن سيد رؤوف قبل ان تسمي بعض الاسماء
نتنياهو يعتبر بان هذه المجموعه ليست
اقليه كل من خرجوا خرجوا تحركهم المعارضه
تفضل
المجموعه الهامشيه التي بداتم فيها هي جزء
هي هامشي في الحمله الاحتجاجيه التي نراها
اليوم
الاغلبيه الساحقات التي تعمل وتتظاهر في
الشوارع فعلا وانا اتضامن معهم بطريقه او
باخرى في هناك مخاوف الاصلاحات القضائيه
قد تشكل تغيير جزري بنمط الحكومه والنمط
النظام الاسرائيلي
وطبعا لهذه المخاوف اساس حيث ان
وزير العدل الاسرائيلي واوضح اكثر من مره
ان هناك فقط تغيير
القضاه ولكن اليوم نشهد يعني تعامل
ومفاوضات ما بين بني جانس من من رؤساء
المعارضه وبين
عناصر
مهمه جدا في حزب اليقود بغيه الوصول
لتسويه انا لا انصح احد
ان يغامر انه في هناك سوف يكون انقلاب او
تغيير
فلتان
الى هذا الحد من التوقعات ولكن
ولكن لازلنا نناقش طبيعه هذه المظاهرات في
الواقع وهنا سؤال سيد سريف هل تتفق مع سيد
رغوفين بانه هذه المظاهرات هي مظاهرات
مشروعه حتى وان كانت هناك اقليه حاضره
تحاول فرض البلبله ام ان كما يقول نتنياهو
كل هذه المظاهرات تحركها المعارضه يقول
بان هذه المظاهرات تخرج لاسباب سياسيه
لاكثر
اولا مسموح للمعارضه ان تتظاهر وان تعبر
عن احتجاجها تعمل كل شيء الا هذه هي
التقاء غير ملائم
لمصالحها يعني في مجتمع ديمقراطي مسموح
للقوه للكل ان يتظاهر ويعبر عن وجهه نظره
هذا اشي واضح ومفهوم ومفهوم للكل المرحله
الذي احنا موجودين فيها هي مرحله الذي لم
تكون في
السنوات الماضيه يعني كانت في مجتمع
الاسرائيلي
عبر عن كثير من الازمات خلال سبعين سنه
الذي هذه الدوله عايشه من 48 لغايه الان
ولكن هذه الازمه هي تضع السؤال الكبير
هو ما هي نوعيه هذه الدوله ما هي
طبيعه هذه الدوله الذي احنا نريد ان نعيش
فيها
والان متبين بالنسبه للمعارضه بالنسبه
للناس المحتجين في الشوارع انه في هناك
محاوله للتغيير النظام الاسرائيلي
قد يكون اقل ديمقراطي من اللي هو اليوم
وهذا يعني يعني يخلق نوع من الحساسيات بين
الكثير من المجموعات التي موجوده داخل
اسرائيل يعني في هناك انت عارفه يعني في
اسرائيل في هناك
شعب كثير او مجموعات كثيره على
الذي تريد ان تشعر بالحريه
والمساواه بين مره ورجل وكمان هناك اشياء
جنسيه الذي
وكثيره الحقيقه
قراناها
قراناها طيله هذه الايام ولكن اخذنا
النقطه اخرى جد مهمه وهي نقطه تغيير
النظام في داخل الاسرائيلي ربما سنتابع
هذه النقطه بالمزيد من المعلومات والنقاش
ولكن في حلقات اخرى من تل ابيب رعوفينبارك
وامنيون سابق ومحاضر ومن تل ابيب كذلك
الدكتور يحنن التوريف كبير الباحثين في
معهد الامن القومي شكرا لكما